OK America, prepare to have your life change for the better. There is a situation that you find yourself in all the time. And it has been unclear what to say or do in that situation until now.
好了，美国，准备好迎接你们的生活向更好的方向转变吧。有一种情况你们总是会遇到。直到现在，在这种情况下该说什么或做什么还不清楚。
We heard about it, and it was like Post-its. It was just all of the sudden something that you needed to use all the time. It just explained so much.
我们听说了这件事，它就像便利贴一样。突然之间，它就成了你需要一直使用的东西。它解释了太多事情。
That's Nancy Updike, one of the regular contributors to our radio show. And she tells the story this way. A couple years ago, friends of hers were traveling in Europe, and they are walking through these old buildings. And these people do not know anything special about architecture. But you know how it is when you're a tourist. They're walking through these buildings, and they're looking at the doorways and the tiles. And they decide that they think that this one building has a very Moorish influence. And they're pointing out details, and saying the Moors this, and the Moors that. And finally, one of them turns to the other and says, you know what? We sound like we're in a magazine, a magazine called Modern Jackass.
那是南希·厄普代克，我们广播节目的常驻撰稿人之一。她是这样讲这个故事的：几年前，她的朋友们在欧洲旅行，走在这些古老的建筑中。这些人对建筑一无所知。但你们知道作为游客是什么感觉。他们走在这些建筑里，看着门框和瓷砖。他们认定这座建筑有非常浓厚的摩尔风格。他们指着细节，说着“摩尔人这个”、“摩尔人那个”。最后，其中一个人转向另一个人说：“你知道吗？我们听起来就像是在一本杂志里，一本叫《现代混蛋》的杂志。”
Modern Jackass. Of course, there is no Modern Jackass . But ever since I heard that story, I found myself referring to Modern Jackass all the time. It's incredibly useful, and it could be useful to you, to back out of all kinds of awkward conversational situations.
《现代混蛋》。当然，并没有《现代混蛋》这本杂志。但自从我听到那个故事后，我发现自己一直在引用《现代混蛋》。它非常有用，对你来说也可能很有用，可以帮你摆脱各种尴尬的谈话局面。
The thing about Modern Jackass is, it's usually not something about which you know nothing. It's something about which you know a little bit, enough to sort of get yourself into trouble.
关于《现代混蛋》的一点是，这通常不是你一无所知的事情。而是你稍微了解一点点的事情，足以让你陷入麻烦。
Like you read an article.
就像你读过一篇文章。
Exactly, or something on the web.
没错，或者在网上看到过什么。
Just last weekend, I was out for breakfast with some friends. And we got into this conversation about these people who do caloric restriction. Have you heard about this? Apparently, there are these people who believe that if you eat a lot less, it can make you live longer. As so we're talking about this, and somebody's explaining the cells of your body go through all this wear and tear when you actually digest food. And before you know it, one of my friends-- somebody who knows nothing about biology, actually-- starts talking about mitochondria. Mitochondria. And maybe he had a little bit of knowledge about this. But it was totally Modern Jackass . Modern Jackass , the medical edition, which Nancy says that she finds herself in quite a bit.
就在上周末，我和一些朋友出去吃早餐。我们聊起了那些进行热量限制的人。你听说过这个吗？显然，有些人相信如果你吃得少得多，就能活得更久。当我们谈论这个时，有人解释说，当你消化食物时，你的身体细胞会经历各种磨损。没过多久，我的一个朋友——其实他对生物学一无所知——就开始谈论线粒体。线粒体。也许他对此有一点点了解。但这完全是《现代混蛋》，医学版。南希说她发现自己经常陷入这种情况。
My mother sends me information about partially hydrogenated oils. And then when somebody says, wait, why is partially hydrogenated oil bad again? I say, well, it's an unstable compound, which it is. It's oil to which hydrogen has been added in order to make it solid at room temperature. That I know. That's a fact.
我母亲给我发送关于部分氢化油的信息。然后当有人说：“等等，为什么部分氢化油又是不好的？”我说：“嗯，它是一种不稳定的化合物，事实确实如此。”它是为了让油在室温下呈固态而添加了氢的油。这一点我知道。这是一个事实。
And why would that be bad, Nancy?
南希，为什么那会不好呢？
Well, that's where we get into Modern Jackass territory. It's unstable in your body. There's an extra hydrogen atom that can interact with things.
嗯，这就是我们进入《现代混蛋》领域的地方。它在你的体内不稳定。有一个额外的氢原子可以与事物发生相互作用。
Oxygen and form water.
与氧气反应形成水。
Exactly.
完全正确。
Having no information, that's one thing. That's pure. The trouble is when you have a little bit of information about the problems with electronic voting machines, what it really means, the battle between carbs and protein. It's hard for some people not to take the tiny pigment contained in that tiny bit of information and paint a vast canvas of the entire world. It is exactly the problem that people encounter in every story in our program today.
一无所知是一回事。那是纯粹的。麻烦在于当你对电子投票机的弊端、它真正的含义、碳水化合物和蛋白质之间的争论有一点了解时。有些人很难不拿那一点点知识里包含的微小碎片，去描绘整个世界的宏大图景。这正是我们今天节目中每个人在每个故事中所遇到的问题。
It's This American Life, from WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. Today we bring you four stories of people taking a smidgen, a tiny smidgen of understanding, and stretching it far past the breaking point. Because as everybody knows, all over the world, a little bit of knowledge can be a very entertaining thing. We have Dan Savage matching wits with a six year old boy. Stay with us.
这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。今天我们带给你们四个故事，讲述人们拿着一点点，一点点微小的理解，并将其延伸到远远超出临界点的程度。因为正如每个人所知，在世界各地，一点点知识可能是一件非常有趣的事情。我们有丹·萨维奇与一个六岁男孩斗智斗勇。请继续收听。
Act One, When Small Thoughts Meet Big Brains. We have this story about people functioning with a tiny little bit of knowledge, long past the point that you think they would, from Alex Blumberg.
第一幕，当小思想遇到大脑袋。我们有这个故事，讲述人们带着一点点微小的知识，在远远超出你认为他们会停止的程度之后，依然继续运作，来自亚历克斯·布隆伯格。
I can reconstruct the events that led me to one of the most embarrassing conversations of my adult life. The chain starts back when I was 11 or 12, and I first heard the term Nielsen family. I was probably listening to some adults talk. And from their conversation I gathered that networks consulted Nielsen families to find out how popular a television show was. But that didn't make sense. Why would they only ask people named Nielsen which shows they liked. I started thinking.
我可以重现导致我成年生活中最尴尬谈话之一的事件。这条链条始于我11或12岁时，我第一次听到“尼尔森家庭”这个词。我可能是在听一些成年人交谈。从他们的谈话中，我推断出电视网咨询尼尔森家庭来了解电视节目的受欢迎程度。但这说不通。为什么他们只问姓尼尔森的人喜欢什么节目？我开始思考。
I knew that when they figured things like this out, they didn't ask everybody, they just asked a small percentage of people, and then extrapolated. I think I figured they had done some research and found that the name Nielsen-- because it was a common name maybe, and it seemed to cut across class and economic lines-- actually came pretty close to a representative sample. I knew this wasn't the way they measured public opinion now, but it seemed like the Nielsen surveys had been around for a while. And I figured they were just a holdover from a more primitive, less statistically rigorous time. After that, I really didn't think about it again. Or if I did, it was only with a mild curiosity. I wonder why TV still does it that way?
我知道当他们计算这类事情时，他们不会问每个人，他们只是问一小部分人，然后进行推断。我想我推断他们做了一些研究，发现“尼尔森”这个名字——也许因为它是一个常见的名字，而且看起来跨越了阶级和经济界限——实际上相当接近一个代表性样本。我知道这并不是他们现在衡量公众舆论的方式，但看起来尼尔森调查已经存在一段时间了。我以为它们只是一个更原始、统计上不那么严谨时代的遗留物。在那之后，我真的没有再想过它。或者如果我想过，也只是带着一种轻微的好奇。我想知道为什么电视仍然那样做？
Fast forward 20 years. I was talking with a friend of mine, who was telling me about her friend, who had been selected to be a Nielsen family. And I said to her, isn't that weird that they're all named Nielsen? My friend looked at me for what seemed like a long time. Somewhere during her very long pause-- because of the very long pause, in fact-- I realized, of course they're not all named Nielsen. That makes no sense at all. At the time of this conversation, I was 34 years old, and I couldn't believe I had gotten this far without ever stopping to think it through. It made me wonder what else I'd missed, and if this has ever happened to anyone besides me.
快进20年。我和我的一个朋友交谈，她告诉我她的朋友被选为尼尔森家庭。我对她说：“他们都姓尼尔森，这不是很奇怪吗？”我的朋友看了我一眼，那眼神似乎持续了很长时间。在她那非常长的停顿期间——事实上，正因为那非常长的停顿——我意识到，当然他们并非都姓尼尔森。那根本说不通。在那次谈话时，我34岁了，我无法相信我竟然活到了这个岁数却从未停下来思考清楚。这让我怀疑我还错过了什么，以及这种情况是否曾经发生在除我之外的任何人身上。
When I was a kid, and I would see the school crossing signs, and there's the picture of the little kids walking, and it would say school x-ing And I thought that the x-ing was a word. And I pronounced it zing.
小时候，当我看到学校的人行横道标志时，上面有小孩子走路的图片，写着“学校 X-ing”，我以为“x-ing”是一个单词。我把它读成“zing”（嗖）。
Turns out, I'm not alone. I've been talking to people about this for weeks. And there are a lot of us out there-- like me and this woman, Jodie Mace-- carting around our childhood beliefs well into adulthood. Jodie thought there were lots of zings, deer zings, railroad zings. That makes sense.
事实证明，我并不孤单。几周来我一直在和人们谈论这件事。我们中间有很多人——就像我和这位女士，朱迪·梅斯——把我们的童年信念一直带到了成年。朱迪以为有很多“zing”，鹿“zing”，铁路“zing”。这倒说得通。
When I was in my 20s, and I was walking into work, and about 10 geese walked in front of me on the sidewalk. So I just turned to my coworker and casually said, it looks like they should have a zing sign there for the geese. There was a sort of long, awkward silence. And I thought that he was thinking, you know, that really is a good idea. But instead, he finally said, you know, zing isn't a word.
我20多岁时，正走去上班，大约10只鹅走在人行道上我面前。所以我只是转向我的同事，随口说：“看起来它们应该在那里有个‘zing’标志给鹅。”有一种很长的、尴尬的沉默。我以为他在想，你知道，这确实是个好主意。但相反，他终于说：“你知道，‘zing’不是一个单词。”
In talking to people, I found out that a lot of these lingering misconceptions involve mispronunciation. And often, the mispronunciation survives into adulthood because the mistake just sounds better, or makes more sense.
在与人交谈中，我发现许多这些挥之不去的误解涉及发音错误。而且通常，这种发音错误会延续到成年，因为错误的发音听起来更好，或者更有道理。
It should be a word, and it should be zing. You don't want a kid to walk slowly across the crossing. If he's smart, he's going to zing.
它应该是一个词，而且它应该是“zing”。你不想让孩子在过马路时走得慢。如果他聪明，他就会“zing”地跑过去。
Consider the word misled. I talked to three people, including my own father, who used to pronounce it mizeled. All three believed it was the past tense of a nonexistent verb, mizel, which means to deceive or to mislead. There's another guy I spoke to who thought, well into his early 20s, that the word quesadilla was Spanish for what's the deal?
考虑“misled”（被误导）这个词。我和三个人谈过，包括我自己的父亲，他们过去常把它读成“mizeled”。所有三个人都认为它是动词“mizel”的过去式，这个动词不存在，意思是指欺骗或误导。我还和另一个人谈过，他到20岁出头还认为“quesadilla”（墨西哥油炸玉米饼）在西班牙语里是“这是什么情况？”的意思。
Most of the common childhood myths, like that babies come from storks, get corrected sooner or later. They're not obscure enough to sneak into adulthood unscrutinized. But occasionally, even a very popular childhood myth can make it through, like unicorns.
大多数常见的童年神话，比如婴儿来自鹳鸟，迟早会被纠正。它们不够晦涩，不足以在不被审查的情况下溜进成年期。但偶尔，即使是一个非常受欢迎的童年神话也能幸存下来，比如独角兽。
In my head, a unicorn wasn't really any different than a zebra.
在我脑海里，独角兽和斑马没什么不同。
This is Kristy Kruger.
这是克里斯蒂·克鲁格。
I mean, in terms of believability, I think the unicorn is really ahead of the dinosaur.
我是说，就可信度而言，我认为独角兽比恐龙真的要领先。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
Well, I mean, when you think about a dinosaur from a kid's perspective, a dinosaur is these really large, monstrous animals roaming the Earth. And then you have a unicorn, which is basically just a horse with a horn.
嗯，我是说，当你从孩子的角度思考恐龙时，恐龙是那些在地球上漫游的真正巨大、可怕的动物。然后你有独角兽，它基本上就是一匹长角的马。
As Kristy Kruger grew up, she says that if she ever thought about unicorns, they were on a grassy plane somewhere in Africa, drinking from a watering hole with the wildebeest and the impala. And then one night, she found herself in a conversation at a party.
随着克里斯蒂·克鲁格长大，她说如果她曾经想到独角兽，它们是在非洲某处的草地上，与角马和黑斑羚一起在水坑边喝水。然后一天晚上，她发现自己在派对上进行了一场谈话。
It was about a group of five to seven people, kind of standing around the keg, just talking. And somehow a discussion of endangered species came up, in which I posed the question, is the unicorn endangered or extinct? And basically, there was a big gap of silence.
那大约是五到七个人围在桶边聊天。不知怎么地，谈到了濒危物种，我提出了一个问题：“独角兽是濒危还是灭绝了？”基本上，出现了一个巨大的沉默空档。
As you might be gathering, at some point in all these stories, you come to a big gap of silence.
正如你们可能正在收集的信息，在所有这些故事的某个时刻，你都会遇到一个巨大的沉默空档。
And then everybody laughed. And then that laughter was followed by more silence when they realized I wasn't laughing. And I was like, yeah, oh God, unicorns aren't real? Oh no.
然后每个人都笑了。然后那种笑声之后是更多的沉默，因为他们意识到我并没有笑。我说：“是啊，噢天哪，独角兽不是真的？噢，不。”
Sometimes a ridiculous belief will survive into adulthood, and it's our parents who are to blame. Robin didn't think there was anything strange about the way she was raised. She lived together with her sister and her parents in a nice house in the suburbs. She went to school like the other kids, watched TV and did her homework. And she ate the exact same thing for dinner every night of her life, baked chicken.
有时一个荒谬的信念会存活到成年，而这要怪我们的父母。罗宾不认为她的成长方式有什么奇怪的。她和她的姐妹及父母住在郊区一栋不错的房子里。她像其他孩子一样上学，看电视，做家庭作业。而且她每天晚餐都吃同样的东西，烤鸡。
It was like Monday, chicken. Tuesday, chicken. Wednesday, chicken. Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Sunday, chicken, chicken chicken, chicken, chicken, every night of my life until I left for college. At the end of the first week of college-- when everyone's desperately trying to fit in, and it's important that you act cool and sophisticated and whatever-- everyone begins complaining about the food that we're being served. What was the hard stuff in the sloppy joe? What was that mystery meat? What animal did it come from?
就像周一，鸡肉。周二，鸡肉。周三，鸡肉。周四、周五、周六、周日，鸡肉、鸡肉、鸡肉、鸡肉、鸡肉，在我离开去上大学之前的每一天晚上。大学第一周结束时——当每个人都在拼命想融入，而且表现得酷、世俗等等很重要的时候——每个人都开始抱怨学校提供的食物。那种糊状肉三明治（sloppy joe）里的硬东西是什么？那种神秘肉是什么？它来自什么动物？
And I'm looking at these people like they are crazy. The variety we are getting here every night. Every night there's a different meal. One night it's mac and cheese. One night it's mystery meat. One night it's sloppy joe. I was like, how can you criticize? I mean, it's a testament to what great chefs they must be that they can make a different meal every single night of the week. And they just kind of stared. And they're like, what? And I'm like, what, what?
我看着这些人，就像他们疯了一样。我们每天晚上得到的种类。每天晚上都是不同的餐点。一晚是通心粉加奶酪。一晚是神秘肉。一晚是糊状肉三明治。我想，怎么能批评呢？我的意思是，这证明了他们一定是多么伟大的厨师，才能在每周的每个晚上都做出不同的餐点。他们只是盯着看。他们说：“什么？”我说：“什么，什么？”
What's running through my head is, wait a minute, these people are implying that they had variation in their meal plan for their entire life. It's mind-bending. I mean, I don't care what I learned throughout college. This is the revelation that has stuck with me. This is what I've learned. All of a sudden like, holy God.
我脑子里想的是，等一下，这些人暗示他们一生中餐点都有变化。这太令人费解了。我的意思是，我不在乎我在大学里学到了什么。这是一直伴随着我的启示。这就是我学到的。突然之间就像，神啊。
When Robin came home for Thanksgiving that year, and confronted her mother with the startling fact that everyone else ate things besides chicken growing up, her mother just shrugged her shoulders and said, you liked chicken. Robin had to concede the point. Even when they'd gone out to restaurants, Robin ordered chicken. They all had.
当罗宾那年感恩节回家，并向她母亲面对那个惊人的事实，即其他人成长过程中除了鸡肉还吃别的东西时，她母亲只是耸了耸肩说：“你喜欢吃鸡肉。”罗宾不得不承认这一点。即使他们去餐馆，罗宾点的也是鸡肉。他们全家都这样。
Here's one more. When Harriet Lerner was a girl, her family was going through some lean years. There were two kids, the house needed repairs. There wasn't much money for holiday gifts. Harriet was seven and she wanted a bike. Her sister Susan was 12. She wanted a set of encyclopedias. But when they came downstairs on Christmas morning, there were only two small boxes waiting for them.
再说一个。当哈丽特·勒纳还是个女孩时，她的家庭经历了一些贫困的年份。家里有两个孩子，房子需要修理。节日礼物没多少钱。哈丽特七岁，想要一辆自行车。她的妹妹苏珊12岁。她想要一套百科全书。但当她们圣诞节早上走下楼时，只有两个小盒子等着她们。
What was inside them-- and we both had exactly the same gift-- were these real ugly, metal tissue holders painted black, with these corny red and yellow roses. They were painted with these cheesy looking red and yellow roses. And I looked at my tissue box, and I started to cry. And I looked at my big sister Susan, and I thought, of course she was going to cry too. And she looked like maybe she was going to cry. But then she sort of put on a big smile. And then she told me that the boxes were painted by trained monkeys.
盒子里装的是什么——我们俩收到的礼物完全一样——是这些真正丑陋、漆成黑色的金属纸巾盒，上面有俗气的红黄玫瑰。它们被漆上了那些看起来俗气的红黄玫瑰。我看着我的纸巾盒，开始哭。我看着我的姐姐苏珊，我想，她当然也会哭。她看起来好像要哭了。但后来她露出了一个大大的微笑。然后她告诉我，这些盒子是由训练有素的猴子画的。
The box became Harriet's prized possession. She kept it on display in her room through elementary school, through high school. Her friends asked her about it, she'd say, oh yeah, it was painted by trained monkeys. Nobody ever challenged her on it, maybe because she believed it herself so completely. And then one day, she was home from college, back in the house where she grew up.
这个盒子成了哈丽特最珍贵的财产。她在小学、高中期间一直把它放在房间里展示。朋友们问她关于它的事，她说：“哦，是的，这是由训练有素的猴子画的。”从来没有人挑战过她，也许是因为她自己完全相信这一点。然后有一天，她从大学回家，回到她长大的房子里。
And I'm going through some papers, or maybe I was snooping through Susan's papers, and I found a composition, and it had her name on it. And she had written it in high school. And it was called "The Tissue Box Story." So I sat down on the floor of Susan's bedroom to read this composition. And Susan told the story just as I told it, except that she wrote how she felt when she saw me crying. And how she then looked at my parents, and saw that my mother was about to cry too. And how she looked at the tissue boxes, and then she remembered that my father had a friend who made them. And she knew how much my parents hated taking charity.
我正在翻看一些文件，或者也许我在翻看苏珊的文件，我发现了一篇作文，上面有她的名字。那是她在高中时写的。它叫“纸巾盒的故事”。所以我坐在苏珊卧室的地板上读这篇作文。苏珊讲的故事和我讲的一模一样，除了她写了当我看到我哭时她是什么感受。以及她后来怎么看着我的父母，看到我母亲也要哭了。以及她看着那些纸巾盒，然后她记得我父亲有个朋友做了这些。她知道我父母有多讨厌接受施舍。
And suddenly, even though she was about to cry, she forced herself to smile. And she pretended those boxes were painted by trained monkeys. And of course, I didn't know any of this. But the funny thing she wrote in her composition is that she just rushed upstairs and started crying all over her pillow. And she wasn't really sad about the gift really, is what she said in the composition. She wasn't sure why she was crying, except that it was sort of like she had volunteered to be a grown up before she was even ready for it.
突然之间，尽管她当时也要哭，她还是强迫自己微笑。她假装那些盒子是训练有素的猴子画的。当然，我不知道这些。但她在作文里写的有趣的事情是，她只是冲上楼梯，在枕头上大哭起来。她说那不是因为礼物，并不是真的因为礼物，她是这么写的。她不确定自己为什么哭，只是觉得这就像她在还没准备好之前就志愿成为一个成年人。
Up until that moment, I had never thought to question my sister's story. I had never subjected it to the scrutiny of a grown up mind. I mean, I was 20. I don't know, I had this tissue box that was painted by trained monkeys. And then it wasn't painted by trained monkeys, really.
直到那一刻，我从未想过质疑我姐姐的故事。我从未把它置于成年人心智的审视之下。我的意思是，我20岁了。我不知道，我有这个由训练有素的猴子画的纸巾盒。然后它实际上不是由训练有素的猴子画的。
Up until reading that story, Harriet thought that her sisters lies had been only to torment her, like the time Harriet swallowed an apple seed, and her big sister convinced her that she had an apple tree growing inside her. She had always been jealous of her sister, always wanted to be the big sister. But reading her sister's story that day made her realize how responsible her sister felt for her, and for their entire family, and how there were benefits to being the baby. It was good to learn all that.
读到那个故事之前，哈丽特以为她姐姐的谎言只是为了折磨她，比如哈丽特吞下一个苹果籽的那次，她姐姐说服她，说她肚子里长了一棵苹果树。她一直嫉妒她的姐姐，一直想成为那个大姐姐。但那天读到她姐姐的故事让她意识到她姐姐对她，以及对他们整个家庭感到多么负责，以及作为最小的孩子有什么好处。学到这一切真好。
But the vision of the lie-- that we live in a world where monkeys can be trained to paint-- is hard to give up.
但是那个谎言的愿景——我们生活在一个猴子可以被训练去绘画的世界里——很难放弃。
And really, it's just that I can still picture this tissue box, and how much I loved it, this tissue box painted by trained monkeys.
而且真的，只是我仍然能想象这个纸巾盒，以及我是多么爱它，这个由训练有素的猴子画的纸巾盒。
I know what she means. For me, there's something appealingly weird about a world where only people who happened to have been born with the name Nielsen get to decide what goes on television. And not long after the day that Jodie Mace's coworker set her straight about the word zing, she found herself on the opposite side of the exact same situation. She was having a conversation with another coworker, and he asked her if elves were real. Elves? Like that live in the forest, she asked, with the pointy toes? He nodded. She paused. And then she said, yeah, of course they are.
我知道她的意思。对我来说，在一个只有恰好出生时叫尼尔森这个名字的人才能决定电视上播什么的世界里，有些古怪之处，这很有吸引力。在朱迪·梅斯的同事告诉她关于“zing”这个词后的不久，她发现自己处于完全相同情况的对立面。她和另一个同事交谈，他问她精灵是否是真的。精灵？就像住在森林里那种，脚趾尖尖的那种？他点点头。她停顿了一下。然后她说：“是啊，当然是真的。”
Alex Blumberg is one of the producers of our show.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "ZING ZING, ZOOM ZOOM" BY PERRY COMO]
[音乐 - 佩里·科莫的《ZING ZING, ZOOM ZOOM》]
Act Two, And Daddy Makes Three. Around the time in 2004 that gay couples were starting to marry in San Francisco, and gay marriage became a hot national issue in the presidential race, Dan Savage found that his own family became very interested in the subject, but in ways that seemed to defy every stereotype. Dan's mom-- a nice Catholic lady from Chicago's North Side-- wanted him to marry his longtime boyfriend, Terry. Dan's dad-- a Republican and former Chicago cop-- felt exactly the same way. And they felt this way for the most traditional reasons-- commitment, love.
第二幕，三个爸爸。2004年左右，当同性恋伴侣开始在旧金山结婚，同性婚姻成为总统竞选中的一个热门全国性议题时，丹·萨维奇发现他自己的家庭对这个话题非常感兴趣，但方式似乎违背了所有的刻板印象。丹的妈妈——一位来自芝加哥北区的和善的天主教女士——希望他与长期的伴侣特里结婚。丹的爸爸——一位共和党人和前芝加哥警察——感觉完全一样。他们出于最传统的原因——承诺、爱——有这种感觉。
Meanwhile, Dan and Terry, the actual couple, the actual homosexuals in the story, they weren't even sure if they wanted to get married. And there was one person in the family who was adamantly opposed to gay marriage. Here's Dan.
与此同时，丹和特里，故事中真正的伴侣，真正的同性恋者，他们甚至不确定是否想结婚。家庭中有一个人坚决反对同性婚姻。这是丹。
Even my mother has spoken to him, but he refuses to budge. Boys don't marry boys, he insists, and girls don't marry girls. He has also made it clear that if Terry and I ever married, he would refuse to attend the ceremony. Who is this stubborn relative? My father, the family's sole Republican? Terry's born again Christian brother? My sister's Texan boyfriend? No, try our six year old adopted son, DJ.
即使是我母亲也和他说过话，但他拒绝让步。男孩不娶男孩，女孩不嫁女孩，他坚持说。他还明确表示，如果特里和我结婚，他拒绝参加仪式。这个顽固的亲戚是谁？我的父亲，家里唯一的共和党人？特里重生的基督徒兄弟？我姐姐的得克萨斯男友？不，试试我们六岁的养子，DJ。
One of his first pronouncements on the issue came when he was just four, when he announced from the back seat of the car that Terry and I didn't really love each other. Why not, we asked. Because you're not married, DJ explained calmly. People who don't love each other don't get married. And since you're not married and can't get married, that means you can't love each other, not really.
他对这个问题最早的宣示之一是在他四岁时，当时他从车后座宣布特里和我并没有真正相爱。为什么不，我们问。因为你们没有结婚，DJ冷静地解释说。不爱对方的人不会结婚。既然你们没结婚，也不能结婚，那意味着你们不能相爱，至少不是真正地相爱。
We traced the circular logic back to its source, a five year old girl. When her parents divorced, they told their only daughter they couldn't stay married because they weren't in love anymore. These words bounced around the little rock tumbler that is her mind until an opportunity to wound another child presented itself to her. Her parents weren't in love anymore and couldn't stay married, she told DJ. And since his parents can't get married, we can't love each other.
我们追踪这种循环逻辑回到它的源头，一个五岁的小女孩。当她父母离婚时，他们告诉他们唯一的女儿，他们不能保持婚姻关系，因为他们不再相爱了。这些话在她那小小的脑海里反弹，直到一个伤害另一个孩子的机会摆在她面前。她说，她父母不再相爱，不能维持婚姻了，告诉DJ。既然他的父母不能结婚，我们也不能相爱。
We have done our best to root this notion out, explaining to DJ that marriage is a promise two people make each other. And that while most men marry women, and most women marry men, men can marry men and women can marry women. We've made a point of showing him same sex wedding announcements in the Style section in the Sunday New York Times . We watched some same sex weddings in the evening news. And after two years of exposure to the liberal media, DJ now concedes that we could get married. But he nevertheless insist that we shouldn't.
我们尽了最大努力根除这种观念，向DJ解释婚姻是两个人向对方许下的承诺。虽然大多数男人娶女人，大多数女人嫁男人，但男人可以娶男人，女人可以嫁女人。我们特意给他看《纽约时报》周日版风格版上的同性婚礼公告。我们在晚间新闻里看了同性婚礼。经过两年自由派媒体的熏陶，DJ现在承认我们可以结婚了。但他仍然坚持认为我们不应该结婚。
If we do get married, he insists that he's not coming to the wedding. He'll come to the party after the wedding, provided there is cake, but there is no way he is going to the ceremony. He agrees that we can love each other, but he insists that boys don't marry boys, and girls don't marry girls, and no gay wedding announcements in The New York Times are going to change his mind. It's odd to reflect that my 64 year old Catholic mom-- raised to view marriage as a sacrament-- believes marriage is about love and commitment, not about genitals. But my six year old son-- raised by a gay couple, and not having seen the inside of a church since the day he was baptized-- somehow came to believe that marriage is about matched sets of boys and girls. How'd that happen?
他说，如果我们结婚，他不会参加婚礼。他会参加婚礼后的派对，前提是有蛋糕，但他绝对不会参加仪式。他同意我们可以相爱，但他坚持认为男孩不娶男孩，女孩不嫁女孩，《纽约时报》上的同性婚礼公告也无法改变他的想法。回想一下，我那64岁的天主教妈妈——从小被教育将婚姻视为圣礼——相信婚姻是关于爱和承诺，而不是关于生殖器，这很奇怪。但我六岁的儿子——由一对同性伴侣抚养大，自受洗那天起就没见过教堂内部——却不知怎么相信婚姻是关于男孩和女孩的匹配。那是怎么发生的？
DJ's traditional position on gender is not something he learned at home. While he was always into all the traditional boy things-- cars, trucks, guns-- until he was four, the boy things he liked were just the things he happened to like. He liked guns because he liked guns, not because boys were supposed to like guns. Then one day we packed DJ off to preschool. The teachers at his progressive Montessori school would sooner feed children tacks than force boys to do boy things and girls to do girl things. No, it was the other children who indoctrinated DJ into the world of gender expectations.
DJ对性别的传统立场不是他在家里学到的。虽然他一直喜欢所有传统的男孩玩意儿——汽车、卡车、枪——但在他四岁之前，他喜欢的男孩玩意儿只是他碰巧喜欢的东西。他喜欢枪是因为他喜欢枪，而不是因为男孩应该喜欢枪。然后有一天我们把DJ送到了学前班。他那先进的蒙台梭利学校的老师，宁愿给孩子喂图钉，也不会强迫男孩做男孩的事，女孩做女孩的事。不，是其他孩子向DJ灌输了性别期望的世界。
From day one, it was the boys versus the girls. And there wasn't much the adults could do about it. When the children weren't engaged in Talmudic discussions about which toys or activities were male or female, the boys were chasing the girls around the yard during recess. And what did DJ learn from the other children about marriage? It was a boy and girl thing, his classmates all agreed. And it wasn't an agreeable thing to the boys. Marriage was a weapon, something the girls would threaten to do to the boys if they ever actually caught them. To turn the tables, the girls only had to threaten to marry the boys. Marriage was nuclear cooties. Once the threat was issued, the boys would turn tail and run, the girls chasing after them now, like a bunch of magnetized pinballs whose charge had suddenly reversed.
从第一天起，就是男孩对女孩。成年人对此无能为力。当孩子们没有在讨论哪些玩具或活动是男性或女性的塔木德式讨论时，男孩们在课间休息时在院子里追逐女孩。DJ从其他孩子那里学到了关于婚姻的什么？他的同学都同意，那是男孩和女孩的事。这对男孩来说可不是什么令人愉快的事。婚姻是一种武器，如果女孩真的抓住了男孩，她们会威胁要和他们结婚。为了扭转局势，女孩们只需要威胁要和男孩结婚。婚姻就是核毒菌。一旦威胁发出，男孩们就会转身逃跑，女孩们追在他们后面，就像一群磁性弹珠，电荷突然反转了。
So to DJ, it didn't make any sense that his two dads, both boys, would contemplate marrying each other. Boys weren't supposed to be interested in marriage anymore than they were supposed to be interested in dolls, or dresses, or fairy tales about princesses. Marriage was a girl thing. And since there weren't any girls in our family, why was this subject even coming up?
所以对DJ来说，他的两个爸爸，都是男孩，会考虑结婚，这根本说不通。男孩不应该对婚姻感兴趣，就像他们不应该对洋娃娃、裙子或关于公主的童话故事感兴趣一样。婚姻是女孩的事。既然我们家里没有女孩，为什么会提到这个话题？
Grandma thinks Terry and I should get married, I told DJ one day in the car. Look at me, Daddy, he responded from the backseat. I twisted around and watched as DJ attempted to roll his eyes. Eye rolling is an important interpersonal skill that DJ hasn't quite mastered yet. Instead of rolling his eyes, he looks up and to the left, and slowly rolls his head around his fixed eyes. Are you trying to tell me something, DJ? You know, he answered. I know, but Terry doesn't. He can't see you. So I'll have to tell him. Terry, when I looked back, DJ was nodding his head, which I guess means he wants us to get married.
有一天在车里我告诉DJ，奶奶认为特里和我应该结婚。看我，爸爸，他从后座回应说。我扭过头，看着DJ试图翻白眼。翻白眼是DJ还没有完全掌握的一项重要人际交往技能。他没有翻白眼，而是向上和向左看，然后缓慢地绕着固定的眼睛转动他的头。你在试图告诉我什么吗，DJ？你知道的，他回答说。我知道，但特里不知道。他看不见你。所以我得告诉他。特里，当我回头时，DJ在点头，我猜这意味着他想要我们结婚。
No, DJ said. Rolling my eyes means I don't want you to get married. Why not? Dad, boys don't marry boys. So should we marry some girls, Terry said. No, DJ said. Why not? Aren't boys supposed to marry girls? DJ thought about this for a second. Then he explained that we weren't the kind of boys who marry girls. Since we loved each other, and since we were his dads, we had to live together forever. Married people live together, and we wouldn't be able to do that, since we had to live with each other and be his dads forever. And so we couldn't get married, because then we would have to live with the girls we married and not with each other, which we couldn't do because we were his dads and had to live together forever, because we were his dads.
不，DJ说。翻白眼意味着我不想你们结婚。为什么？爸爸，男孩不娶男孩。那么我们应该娶一些女孩吗，特里说。不，DJ说。为什么？男孩不是应该娶女孩吗？DJ想了这个一会儿。然后他解释说，我们不是那种娶女孩的男孩。既然我们相爱，既然我们是他的爸爸，我们必须永远住在一起。结婚的人住在一起，我们不能那样做，因为我们必须住在一起，永远做他的爸爸。所以我们不能结婚，因为那样我们就不得不和我们娶的女孩住在一起，而不能住在一起，这是我们不能做的，因为我们是他的爸爸，必须永远住在一起，因为我们是他的爸爸。
A few weeks later, DJ woke up in the middle of the night with an earache. I got some Children's Tylenol into him, and we curled up together on the couch in the living room, waiting for the medicine to do its job. We talked about skateboarding. We talked about school. We talked about the cosmic injustice that earaches represent. Then we talked about sex. Dad? I want to be gay with Joshua when I grow up. It was a radical change of topic, but it wasn't a bolt from the blue. DJ had been asking questions lately about what exactly gay meant. He knew he had gay parents, and that gay marriage was always in the news, and that if his parents married, it would be one of those gay marriages.
几周后，DJ半夜醒来，耳朵疼。我给他喂了一些儿童泰诺，我们蜷缩在客厅的沙发上，等着药起作用。我们谈论了滑板。我们谈论了学校。我们谈论了耳朵疼所代表的宇宙不公。然后我们谈论了性。爸爸？我想长大后和约书亚成为同性恋。这是一个激进的话题转换，但并非毫无预兆。DJ最近一直在问“同性恋”到底是什么意思。他知道他有同性恋父母，同性婚姻一直在新闻里，如果他的父母结婚，那将是那些同性婚姻之一。
Despite our best efforts to explain what gayness was without popping in an old Chi Chi LaRue video, DJ was still a little fuzzy on the concept. Apparently, he had concluded that being gay meant living with your best friend. I didn't want to tell DJ that he couldn't be gay when he grew up, but I didn't believe he was going to be gay when he grew up. As best anyone can tell, most kids, over 90%, will grow up to be straight, whether they're raised by gay or straight parents. I almost told him he wouldn't be gay. He plays with trucks. He likes Power Rangers. He threw a perfect spiral the first time he picked up a football. He was throwing it to me and I dropped it, naturally. The kid is straight.
尽管我们尽了最大努力去解释同性恋是什么，而没有播放旧的奇奇·拉鲁（Chi Chi LaRue）视频，但DJ对这个概念还是很模糊。显然，他得出的结论是，成为同性恋意味着和最好的朋友住在一起。我不想告诉DJ他长大后不能成为同性恋，但我也不相信他长大后会成为同性恋。据大家所知，大多数孩子，超过90%，长大后会是异性恋，无论他们是由同性恋还是异性恋父母抚养大。我差点告诉他他不会是同性恋。他玩卡车。他喜欢恐龙战队。他第一次拿起足球就投出了一个完美的螺旋球。他投给我，而我自然地接丢了。这孩子是异性恋。
But on the off chance that he wasn't going to be straight, I started naming all the couples we knew, gay and straight. And DJ joined in. There was Eddie and Mickey, Billy and Kelly, Laura and Joe, Grandma and Gramps, Mark and Diane, Shirley and Rose, Brad and Rachel, Nancy and Barrack, David and Jake, Amy and Sonya, Henry and Beth, Maureen and Ed. Most of the men we know are with? I asked. Girls, DJ said. That's because most men wind up falling in love with women when they grow up. And most women wind up falling in love with men. Those men are called straight. Men who fall in love with men, like me and Daddy, are called gay.
但万一他不打算成为异性恋，我开始列出我们认识的所有情侣，同性恋和异性恋的。DJ也加入了。有艾迪和米奇，比利和凯莉，劳拉和乔，奶奶和爷爷，马克和黛安，雪莉和罗斯，布拉德和瑞秋，南希和巴拉克，大卫和杰克，艾米和索尼娅，亨利和贝丝，莫琳和艾德。我问，大多数我们认识的男人和谁在一起？女孩，DJ说。那是因为大多数男人长大后最终会爱上女人。大多数女人长大后最终会爱上男人。这些男人被称为异性恋。爱上男人的男人，像我和爸爸，被称为同性恋。
Am I going to be gay? I don't know, DJ, but probably not. Most men aren't gay. You could be gay when you grow up, but it's much more likely that you're going to be straight, like Uncle Billy, or Uncle Eddie, or Tim, or Brad. But I want to be gay, like you and Dad. Ah, I thought, somewhere a fundamentalist Christian's heart is breaking. This is precisely what they worry about when they condemn gay parents. Our kids will want to be gay. They will want to emulate their parents and adopt their sexuality. If you believe, against all evidence, that sexuality is a matter of choice, it may be a rational fear. But sexuality isn't a matter of choice. It's an inborn trait. And DJ could no more choose to be gay like his parents than I could choose to be straight, like mine.
我会成为同性恋吗？我不知道，DJ，但可能不会。大多数男人不是同性恋。你长大后可能是同性恋，但你长大后成为异性恋的可能性要大得多，像比利叔叔，或艾迪叔叔，或蒂姆，或布拉德。但我想要成为同性恋，像你和爸爸一样。啊，我想，在某处一个原教旨主义基督徒的心正在破碎。这正是他们谴责同性恋父母时所担心的。我们的孩子会想要成为同性恋。他们会想要模仿他们的父母并采用他们的性取向。如果你相信，尽管没有任何证据，性取向是一种选择，这可能是一种理性的恐惧。但性取向不是一种选择。这是一种先天特质。DJ选择像他父母一样成为同性恋的可能性，和我选择像我父母一样成为异性恋的可能性一样小。
It's not a decision you get to make, I said. It's not a decision I got to make. It's a decision your heart makes. When? When you're older, I said. One day, your heart will let you know whether you're going to be the kind of man who falls in love with a woman or a man. There was a long silence, and I thought DJ had fallen asleep. He was curled up next to me, resting his head against my side, and I couldn't see his face. I stayed very still.
我说，这不是你能做的决定。这不是我能做的决定。这是你的心做的决定。什么时候？我说，等你长大一点。有一天，你的心会让你知道你将成为那种爱上女人还是男人的男人。出现了一阵长久的沉默，我以为DJ睡着了。他蜷缩在我身边，把头靠在我身边，我看不到他的脸。我保持一动不动。
Grandma says you're supposed to marry the person you love, DJ suddenly said. He hadn't fallen asleep. He'd just been quietly working through something. That's right, I said, Grandma does say that all the time. But you love me, and we're not going to get married. Grown up love is a special kind of love. People don't fall in that special kind of love with their sisters or their mothers or their sons. There's something in your heart that makes you go out into the world and find someone new, someone you've never met before, and that's the person you fall in love with. Why? Because that's how new families are made. And one day you'll meet the person you want to make a new family with, and that's the person you're supposed to marry.
奶奶说你应该嫁给你爱的人，DJ突然说。他没睡着。他只是在安静地想通某事。我说，没错，奶奶确实一直这么说。但你爱我，而我们不会结婚。成人的爱是一种特殊的爱。人们不会和他们的姐妹、母亲或儿子坠入那种特殊的爱河。你的心里有什么东西让你走入世界，找到一个新人，一个你从未见过的人，那才是你坠入爱河的人。为什么？因为那是制造新家庭的方式。有一天你会遇到你想和她组建新家庭的人，那个人才是你应该结婚的对象。
Why? Because marriage is a promise that you make to that other person, a promise to stay in love with them forever, to be related forever, so that you'll always be together. Did Henry's parents fall out of love? Henry was a friend of DJ's whose parents were in the middle of an ugly divorce. Yes, they did. So they broke their promise? Yes, I guess they did. DJ got quiet again. Do you and Daddy want to get married? Sometimes we do, I said, but sometimes we don't. Grandma wants us to get married, you don't.
为什么？因为婚姻是你向那个人许下的承诺，一个承诺永远爱他们，永远有亲属关系，这样你们就会永远在一起。亨利的父母不爱对方了吗？亨利是DJ的一个朋友，他的父母正处于一段丑陋的离婚中。是的，他们确实不爱了。所以他们违背了诺言？是的，我想他们确实违背了。DJ又安静了下来。你和爸爸想结婚吗？我说，有时我们想，但有时我们不想。奶奶希望我们结婚，你不想。
I changed my mind. Why? You and dad have to stay together forever. We will, I said. We love each other and always will. DJ sat up on the couch and looked me in the eye. I want you and Daddy to promise, to pinky promise, to seriously and forever promise, and no breaking your promise. You want us to get married then, I said. Yes. And there it was, my reward for a sleepless night. My son was giving me his blessing to marry. I'll tell Terry, I said. We'll see what Daddy says.
我改变主意了。为什么？你和爸爸必须永远在一起。我说，我们会在一起的。我们爱对方，永远都会。DJ坐在沙发上，看着我的眼睛。我希望你和爸爸承诺，拉钩承诺，严肃地、永远地承诺，不能违背诺言。我说，那么你想要我们结婚。是的。就在那儿，我熬夜的奖赏。我的儿子在给我祝福，让我结婚。我说，我会告诉特里。我们会看看爸爸怎么说。
Dan Savage, reading from his book The Commitment , in which his mom and his six year old son wage a battle of ideas. His great, great podcast is available at thestranger.com. Coming up, baby Einstein takes on the real Einstein. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
丹·萨维奇，朗读他的书《承诺》，书中他的妈妈和他六岁的儿子展开了一场思想战。他很棒，很棒的播客可以在thestranger.com上收听。接下来，爱因斯坦宝宝挑战真正的爱因斯坦。那是一分钟后的事，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, A Little Bit of Knowledge, taking a small bit of information and drawing on it. And coming to conclusions and inferences is, of course, a sign of intelligence. We all do that. It's just sometimes, it gets a little complicated. We've arrived at Act Three. Act Three, Sucker MC-Squared. We have this story from Robert Andrew Powell.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你们各种不同种类的故事。今天的节目，一点点知识，拿着一小部分信息并利用它。当然，得出结论和推论是智力的标志。我们都这样做。只是有时，它变得有点复杂。我们已经到了第三幕。第三幕，吸盘MC平方。我们有来自罗伯特·安德鲁·鲍威尔的这个故事。
Bob Berenz didn't come into my life as a physicist. I knew him originally as the goalie on my hockey team. I'd see him every Wednesday night. We'd play hockey for an hour or so, and then he'd go back to his house, and his family, and his job as an electrician. He retired from the team a couple years ago. He was 48, a bit too old to be stopping slap shots. Away from the rink and with extra time on his hands, he hatched an idea for an invention, a superconductor of some sort.
鲍勃·贝伦兹并没有作为一名物理学家走进我的生活。我最初认识他是我们曲棍球队的守门员。我每周三晚上都会见到他。我们会打一个小时左右的曲棍球，然后他会回到他的家，他的家人，以及他作为电工的工作。他几年前从球队退役了。他48岁了，停下猛击球有点太老了。离开了溜冰场，手头有多余的时间，他酝酿了一个发明的想法，某种超导体。
Bob's a tinkerer, great with car engines, computers, any kind of electronics. But to build something as ambitious as a superconductor, he needed to go back and study basic physics, something he hadn't done since high school.
鲍勃是个修补匠，擅长汽车引擎、电脑，任何种类的电子产品。但要建造像超导体这样雄心勃勃的东西，他需要回去学习基础物理，这是他高中之后就没做过的事。
So I sat down, I got out my books and started reading. Of course, I never got to the invention because I found something else, something that I couldn't understand, couldn't resolve. And I think something much more important, because it's something every Nobel Prize-winning physicist missed.
所以我坐下来，拿出我的书开始阅读。当然，我从来没有进行那个发明，因为我发现了别的东西，一些我无法理解、无法解决的东西。我认为这比那个更重要，因为它是每个诺贝尔奖获奖物理学家都错过的事情。
That something, he said, was the most significant development in physics in a century.
他说，那件事是近一个世纪物理学中最重大的发展。
I discovered that physics is fundamentally operating off an incorrect principle. And the principle is that e equals mc squared. That's wrong, without question. It gives you wrong answers every time you use it. I guarantee it.
我发现物理学根本上是在一个不正确的原则下运行的。那个原则就是E等于MC平方。那是错的，毫无疑问。每次你使用它，它都会给你错误的答案。我保证。
Bob believed he'd disproved Einstein's theory of relativity, and that's why he got back in touch with me. I'm a journalist. Bob said he needed my help drafting a book about his findings. He said the book would make him famous. He said it would make us both rich. Bob suggested we call the book E Does Not Equal MC Squared.
鲍勃相信他推翻了爱因斯坦的相对论，这就是他和我重新取得联系的原因。我是个记者。鲍勃说他需要我的帮助来起草一本关于他发现的书。他说这本书会让他出名。他说这会让我们两个都发财。鲍勃建议我们把书名定为《E不等于MC平方》。
I met up with Bob at his small yellow house in South Miami. On his bookshelves, alongside hockey trophies and framed photos of his daughters, stand copies of Physics Demystified, Trigonometry Demystified, and Calculus Demystified. Physics is simple, he says. It's the physics community, academia that mystifies him.
我在他位于南迈阿密的小黄房子里见到了鲍勃。在他的书架上，除了曲棍球奖杯和女儿们的镶框照片外，还放着《物理学揭秘》、《三角学揭秘》和《微积分揭秘》。他说，物理学很简单。是物理学界，学术界，让他感到困惑。
All right, in this point I have to be completely honest. I did write a paper early on, and I submitted it to a physics site. And it was summarily rejected out of hand. But I did learn an important lesson, that physicists and what's being done by them is very complicated, very mathematically intensive. What I've got is none of that, so it completely, almost in reverse, goes over their heads.
好吧，在这一点上我必须完全诚实。我确实写过一篇论文，并提交给了一个物理学网站。它被草率地直接拒绝了。但我确实学到了重要的一课，即物理学家和他们所做的事情非常复杂，数学密度很高。我所拥有的没有这些，所以它完全，几乎是反过来的，超过了他们的理解能力。
OK, we're going to have an arrow. This arrow represents force. I'll put a big letter F there.
好的，我们要有一个箭头。这个箭头代表力。我会在那里放一个大写字母F。
In a nutshell, Bob believes Einstein misunderstood the relationship between energy and time. Bob insists the error is self-explanatory and obvious. But whenever he's tried to show me his reasoning, I don't see it. I can't tell if I'm confused or if Bob's confused.
简而言之，鲍勃认为爱因斯坦误解了能量和时间之间的关系。鲍勃坚持认为这个错误是不言自明的、显而易见的。但每当他试图向我展示他的推理时，我看不出。我分不清是我困惑，还是鲍勃困惑。
--times its velocity. It actually should be mass times speed. It's a mathematical thing, it's no big deal. Unless you're a physicist, then you'll focus on it, to the exclusion of the truth. So if we look at the mass times the speed--
……乘以它的速度。实际上应该是质量乘以速度。这是一个数学上的东西，没什么大不了的。除非你是物理学家，那么你会专注于它，而忽略了真理。所以如果我们看质量乘以速度……
The only physics class Bob ever took was in high school. After graduating, Bob audited a couple college courses, but they weren't for him. Last summer, right before he called me, Bob had decided to give himself a year to find a wider audience for his discovery, a full year, free from electrical work. His wife, Celia, supported this sabbatical. She earned enough money in her corporate job to keep them afloat.
鲍勃上过的唯一物理课是在高中。毕业后，鲍勃旁听过几门大学课程，但不适合他。去年夏天，就在他给我打电话之前，鲍勃决定给自己一年时间来为他的发现寻找更广泛的受众，整整一年，不用做电工工作。他的妻子西莉亚支持这个休假。她在公司工作赚的钱足以维持他们的生活。
What if it's totally true, and I didn't support him? I mean, would I feel like a schmuck or what? I mean, really, it's like, so go for it.
如果这是完全正确的，而我没有支持他呢？我的意思是，我会觉得自己是个笨蛋还是什么？我的意思是，真的，这就像，那就去做吧。
You can ask Celia if she believes Bob has disproved Einstein. But for her, that's not the point.
你可以问西莉亚她是否相信鲍勃推翻了爱因斯坦。但对她来说，重点不在此。
He felt strongly about it. It's like, just because I don't understand it doesn't mean that it's not real. He's done all this research, and he sits here and does all this studying, and he reads all these books, and he does these tests. I mean, he's the most disciplined individual I have ever known. Just because I don't understand it, doesn't mean a damn thing.
他对此感觉很强烈。就像，仅仅因为我不理解它，并不意味着它不是真的。他做了所有这些研究，他坐在这里做所有这些学习，他读所有这些书，他做这些测试。我的意思是，他是我认识的最自律的人。仅仅因为我不理解，并不意味着一丁点。
Bob's my friend. He was my goalie. I didn't want to be the guy to kill his dream either, and like his wife, I didn't feel qualified to disprove him. Maybe he had stumbled onto something simple and profound. Electrician disproves theory of relativity, that would make for a pretty good book. I told Bob I'd run his work past a trained physicist. This turned out to be more difficult than I had expected.
鲍勃是我的朋友。他是我的守门员。我也不想成为那个扼杀他梦想的人，而且像他妻子一样，我觉得自己没有资格推翻他。也许他偶然发现了一些简单而深刻的东西。电工推翻相对论，那会是一本很不错的书。我告诉鲍勃我会把他的工作拿给一位受过训练的物理学家看。这结果比我预期的更难。
A scientist at the Los Alamos National Laboratory replied to my email with a curt, please don't waste my time again. The head of the Physics Department at the University of Miami dropped Bob's research paper like it was radioactive. He receives one of these papers each week, he said. It turns out, there is a whole community of people out there who also claim to have disproved Einstein's theory. So persistent are these outsiders that John Baez, a Professor of Mathematics in California, felt compelled to publish the crackpot index. It's an online quiz you can take to see if you are, by his definition, a crackpot.
洛斯阿拉莫斯国家实验室的一位科学家用冷淡的“请不要再浪费我的时间了”回复了我的邮件。迈阿密大学物理系主任把鲍勃的研究论文像对待放射性物质一样扔掉了。他说，他每周都会收到这样的一篇论文。原来，外面有一整群人也声称推翻了爱因斯坦的理论。这些局外人如此固执，以至于加州数学教授约翰·贝兹觉得必须发表“怪胎指数”。这是一个你可以参加的在线测验，看看你是否按照他的定义是一个怪胎。
There are 35 items in the index, including 10 points for each favorable comparison of yourself to Einstein. 10 points for each claim that the theory of relativity is fundamentally misguided. 10 points for claiming that your work is on the cutting edge of a quote, "paradigm shift." 10 points for each statement along the lines of, I'm not good at math, but my theory is conceptually right. Here's Baez.
索引中有35个项目，包括将自己与爱因斯坦进行有利比较的每项得10分。声称相对论在根本上是误导性的，每项得10分。声称你的工作处于所谓的“范式转换”前沿，每项得10分。类似“我不擅长数学，但我的理论在概念上是对的”的陈述，每项得10分。这是贝兹。
I'm sure that I've seen at least 100 different crackpot theories. I will get emails from people asking me to help them work out the details of their theory. And so it's sort of like saying I'm good at music, but I just don't know what the notes are supposed to be in this piece. If you could just write down the notes, I could come up with a great piece of music.
我相信我已经看过至少100种不同的怪胎理论。我会收到人们发来的电子邮件，请求我帮他们搞清楚他们理论的细节。这就像是说我擅长音乐，但我只是不知道这首曲子里的音符应该是什么。如果你能写下音符，我就能写出一首伟大的乐曲。
He told me about a few of the more infamous crackpots. One guy who calls himself Ludwig Von Plutonium believes the solar system consists of a single radioactive atom. Another was Alexander Abian.
他告诉我几个更臭名昭著的怪胎。一个自称路德维希·冯·钚的人相信太阳系由单个放射性原子组成。另一个是亚历山大·阿比安。
He was a math professor at the University of Iowa who, in his later years, came up with the theory that all the diseases on Earth are due to the pernicious influence of the moon, and so that we should destroy the moon, in fact.
他是爱荷华大学的一位数学教授，晚年提出了一个理论，即地球上所有的疾病都是由于月球的有害影响，所以我们实际上应该摧毁月球。
Destroy the moon?
摧毁月球？
Yeah, we have to blow it up to prevent the spread of AIDS. And he also had an equation that was sort of like e equals mc squared, something about how energy gets used up pushing time forwards.
是的，为了防止艾滋病的传播，我们必须把它炸掉。他还提出了一个方程，有点像E等于MC平方，关于能量如何被用于推动时间向前发展。
Why do people do this?
为什么人们会这样做？
I think they do it because they really want to understand the universe. And they have very noble, albeit grandiose, motivations, trying to do what us regular physicists also are trying to do for our own noble and grandiose motivations. And I think what distinguishes them from physicists who can make a useful contribution is that they don't want to be somebody whose epitaph says that they tightened the screws on a particle accelerator that made a great experiment. They want to be Einstein. And most of us can't be Einstein. And that's the trouble.
我认为他们这样做是因为他们真的想了解宇宙。他们有非常高尚，尽管宏大的动机，试图做我们常规物理学家也试图做的事情，出于我们自己的高尚和宏大的动机。我认为让他们区别于能做出有用贡献的物理学家的是，他们不想成为那种墓碑上写着“他拧紧了粒子加速器上的螺丝，做了一个伟大的实验”的人。他们想成为爱因斯坦。而我们大多数人成不了爱因斯坦。这就是麻烦所在。
When I told Bob about the index, he had already seen it on the internet, had taken the test, and had concluded that, technically, he's a crackpot. But that never even gave him pause.
当我告诉鲍勃关于索引的事时，他已经在网上看到了，参加了测试，并得出结论，从技术上讲，他是一个怪胎。但这从未让他迟疑。
There is a climate within the physics community-- because they have to go through so many years of study, and such tough mathematics, and this and that-- that anyone who comes into the zone and hasn't gone through the same steps that they have, is looked on with a little bit of disdain. I'll tell you what, I do challenge any real physicist to stand with me on a blackboard, and we'll go over this.
物理学界内有一种氛围——因为他们必须经历这么多年的学习，和如此艰难的数学，等等等等——任何进入这个领域而没有经历过他们所经历步骤的人，都会被稍微轻视。我告诉你们，我确实挑战任何真正的物理学家和我一起站在黑板前，我们会过一遍这个。
Eventually, months later, I did find someone, a real physicist who was willing to take Bob's challenge. I first met Dr. Brant Watson at his office in Miami. On his wall hung a portrait of Albert Einstein, certificates recognizing several patents, and curiously, a poster of some Victoria's Secret lingerie models. Dr. Watson holds a PhD in nuclear physics. He says he enjoys hearing new ideas, and was genuinely interested in reading Bob's paper, which he did. When he finished, he handed me a Kit Kat bar as I explained that Bob had invested close to 12 months in his research.
最终，几个月后，我确实找到了一个人，一位愿意接受鲍勃挑战的真正物理学家。我第一次在迈阿密办公室见到了布兰特·沃森博士。他的墙上挂着阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦的肖像，几项认可专利的证书，还有一个奇怪的维多利亚的秘密内衣模特海报。沃森博士拥有核物理学博士学位。他说他喜欢听新想法，确实对阅读鲍勃的论文感兴趣，他读了。当他读完时，他给了我一块Kit Kat巧克力棒，因为我解释说鲍勃在他的研究中投入了近12个月的时间。
Really?
真的？
Yeah.
是的。
What he came up with took a year?
他想出来的东西花了一年？
He's been working on it for a year.
他已经为此工作了一年。
That's too bad. He should have talked to me a long time before he got started. You can tell when somebody is worth listening to, real quick. I sat in a class at Florida State with Don Robson, who was teaching theoretical physics. And I remember one time, my jaw just dropped, like in a cartoon, but it dropped without me making it do it. How stunned I was to see this beautiful formula that he was writing on the board. And I said, my God, that one formula expresses everything, but I know I could never do it myself. Well Bob, with what he wrote, out of the question.
那太糟糕了。在他开始之前，他早该和我谈谈。你可以很快判断一个人是否值得倾听。我在佛罗里达州立大学的一堂课上坐过唐·罗布森的课，他当时在教理论物理学。我记得有一次，我的下巴掉下来了，就像在动画片里一样，但它掉下来时我并没有让它那样。看到他在黑板上写的那条美丽的公式，我是多么震惊。我说，我的上帝，那一个公式表达了一切，但我知道我自己永远做不到。嗯，鲍勃，和他写的那些东西，根本不可能。
Dr. Watson said Bob's work was riddled with the kind of mistakes a freshman physics student would make in his first week of class. No, he corrected, they were the kind of mistakes a freshman sociology student taking a physics elective would make. He said Bob's biggest error was repeatedly confusing momentum with energy, which apparently, in physics, is a big deal.
沃森博士说鲍勃的工作充斥着新生物理学学生在课程第一周就会犯的那种错误。不，他纠正说，那是社会学专业学生修物理选修课会犯的那种错误。他说鲍勃最大的错误是反复把动量和能量弄混，这显然在物理学中是一件大事。
I relayed this to Bob, thinking that would be the end of it. Yet Bob didn't waver. He remained so earnest and so obstinate that I arranged for Bob and Dr. Watson to meet face to face. I thought it would be a quick meeting, that Dr. Watson would turn Bob around. I was wrong.
我把这些转告给鲍勃，以为那会是结局。然而鲍勃并没有动摇。他仍然是那么真诚，那么固执，以至于我安排了鲍勃和沃森博士面对面见面。我以为那会是一次简短的会议，沃森博士会说服鲍勃。我错了。
I do not say momentum is the same thing as kinetic energy.
我并没有说动量和动能是一回事。
Oh no? You did about 10 times in that paper. And I marked every one of them. No, no, no, 10 times in your paper.
噢，没有吗？你在那篇论文里说了大约10次。而且我每一处都标出来了。不，不，不，在你的论文里10次。
Well, I don't want to get into that part of it, because--
嗯，我不想深入那个部分，因为……
That is a part of it. That's what we do it into first. As physicists, the first thing we check is the units. If the units are wrong, then apples equals oranges, which we don't accept. That's a very efficient way to find out if somebody's wrong or not. That's how we do it.
那是其中的一部分。那才是我们要处理的第一件事。作为物理学家，我们检查的第一件事是单位。如果单位错了，那么苹果就等于橙子，我们不接受。这是一种非常有效的发现某人是否错误的方法。我们就是这样做的。
I understand that. Now that's not the issue. The issue is--
我理解。现在那不是问题所在。问题是……
Accord was never reached. Bob and Dr. Watson's frustration with each other devolved into name calling.
从未达成一致。鲍勃和沃森博士对彼此的沮丧演变成了谩骂。
In fact, I have to mention this. Under the hallmark of schizophrenia is, they get a good idea, and then they never investigate whether it's right or not, OK? So this is an ideation.
事实上，我必须提到这一点。精神分裂症的标志之一是，他们有一个好点子，然后他们从不调查它是否正确，好吗？所以这是一种意念。
Are you calling Bob a schizophrenic?
你是在叫鲍勃精神分裂症患者吗？
No, I'm telling you have to watch out for this kind of thing, because some people may think that.
不，我是在告诉你必须小心这种事情，因为有些人可能会那样想。
Finally, Bob, defiant as always, volleyed back with what all along has been his main point: e equals mc squared doesn't make sense because it's difficult to understand. A fundamental law of physics should be self-explanatory.
最后，鲍勃，一如既往地反抗，回击了他一直以来的核心观点：E等于MC平方说不通，因为它很难理解。物理学的一个基本定律应该是显而易见的。
Well, the only thing I can see with physics is you are getting way too complicated. I mean, you have to go to school forever. You have to know this outrageous amount of calculus. When I see all that, I know that physics has gone off the rails.
嗯，我在物理学中唯一能看到的是你们变得太复杂了。我的意思是，你必须永远去学校。你必须知道这种离谱的微积分数量。当我看到所有这些时，我知道物理学已经偏离轨道了。
Let me tell you why it looks so difficult. There comes a point at which you can see beyond the gap, that you'll never cross the gap. You just can't do it. No matter how hard you try, you can't do it. Especially when you got to the conclusion Einstein was wrong, it should be e equals mc, I guess, instead of mc squared. If you used mc, there would have been no A-bomb on Hiroshima. We don't have radios, we don't have lasers, we don't have atomic bombs, we don't have anything. No cellphone, no microwave, no nothing, man. We don't have anything.
让我告诉你为什么它看起来那么难。有一个点，你可以看到超越这个缺口的，你永远跨不过这个缺口。你就是做不到。无论你多么努力，你都做不到。特别是当你得出爱因斯坦是错的结论时，我想应该是E等于MC，而不是MC平方。如果你使用MC，广岛就不会有原子弹。我们没有收音机，我们没有激光，我们没有原子弹，我们什么都没有。没有手机，没有微波炉，什么都没有，伙计。我们什么都没有。
Back at Bob's house, we talked about it. Bob was fuming. Nothing Dr. Watson had said had changed his mind.
回到鲍勃的房子，我们谈论了这件事。鲍勃在冒火。沃森博士说的话什么都没改变他的想法。
How come Brant can't persuade you that you're wrong?
为什么布兰特不能说服你你是错的？
Well, this is not really fair, but I'm going to say it anyway. It's like he was talking the party line. He didn't strike me as being all that bright. I know he has a couple of patents, and he's this big professor, and it's probably not fair for me to say that, but I'm not claiming to be this incredible genius in this one area. It's very simple what I ran into. And I need some help to get it put into a forum where people can understand it. But it really isn't that difficult.
嗯，这真的不公平，但我还是会说。这就像他在说党八股。他给我的印象并不是那么聪明。我知道他有几项专利，他是一位大教授，我那样说可能不公平，但我并没有声称自己在这个领域是一个不可思议的天才。我遇到的事情很简单。我需要一些帮助来把它放入一个人们可以理解的论坛。但它真的没那么难。
I understand Bob's stubbornness this way. Since he was a kid, he was going off and reading books and figuring out things on his own. When he was 12, he taught himself how to construct an FM transmitter from spare parts, building the coil himself. He is a self-taught auto mechanic, and self-taught television repairman too. Almost everything he knows about electrical work he learned from books. He has based his whole life on the idea that he can figure out things on his own, technical stuff that, to most of us, seems just as hard as e equals mc squared. No wonder he thinks he can trust his own judgment on this one. It's a hard habit to break. It's hard for him to see himself any other way.
我是这样理解鲍勃的固执的。从小，他就一直在读书，自己想出事情。当他12岁时，他自学了如何用零配件建造一个调频发射机，自己制造线圈。他是一位自学成才的汽车修理工，也是自学成才的电视修理工。他关于电工工作知道的几乎所有事情都是从书上学来的。他把整个人生建立在这样一个想法上：他可以自己搞清楚事情，对我们大多数人来说，这些技术问题似乎和E等于MC平方一样难。难怪他认为他可以在这一点上相信自己的判断。这是一个很难改掉的习惯。他很难以任何其他方式看待自己。
As the end of Bob's sabbatical neared, I had asked his wife, Celia, about a possibility Bob wouldn't even acknowledge.
当鲍勃的休假接近尾声时，我问了他的妻子西莉亚，一个鲍勃甚至不愿承认的可能性。
What would it mean, in the big picture, if Bob is totally wrong?
从宏观来看，如果鲍勃完全错了，那意味着什么？
I think it would be a huge blow to his ego. It wouldn't change anything for me, as far as how I feel about him. He'd still be Bob, and he'd still be the man I love, and I'd still be in love with him. You have got to love him, man. It's either you love him or hate them. It's like he can be an arrogant son of a bitch. You live with the good and the bad. There's so much more to him than that, than that uncombed and unkempt hair, and the fact that he doesn't keep doctors' appointments, or make them, which makes me the nagging, bitching wife, but that's OK. It's part of the package.
我想这对他的自尊心将是一个巨大的打击。对我来说，改变不了什么，就我对他感觉而言。他仍然是鲍勃，他仍然是我爱的那个男人，我仍然爱着他。伙计，你必须爱他。要么你爱他，要么恨他们。他就像一个傲慢的混蛋。你和好坏一起生活。他远不止这些，不仅仅是那乱蓬蓬的头发，还有他不遵守医生的预约，或者不去预约的事实，这让我成了唠叨的、抱怨的妻子，但没关系。这是整体的一部分。
Bob has returned to his old job, electrifying houses and office buildings. At home, he set aside his physics books to focus on the wiring system on his Carmengia, a clamshell of a car he's rebuilding by himself, from the tires up. He says he's trying to take an engine designed in the 1930s and get it working for the 21st century. It's an ambitious project, complex, challenging, and totally over my head. I have no doubt he'll pull it off.
鲍勃回到了他的旧工作，为房屋和办公楼接电。在家里，他把物理书放在一边，专注于他那辆Carmengia的布线系统，那是一辆他正在自己重建的蚌壳式汽车，从轮胎开始。他说他正试图采用一种1930年代设计的引擎，并让它为21世纪工作。这是一个雄心勃勃的项目，复杂、具有挑战性，完全超出了我的理解能力。我毫不怀疑他会成功。
Robert Andrew Powell is the author of the book We Own This Game about youth football. He's in Boulder, Colorado.
罗伯特·安德鲁·鲍威尔是关于青少年足球的书《我们拥有这场比赛》的作者。他在科罗拉多州博尔德。
[MUSIC - "MODERN PHYSICS IN FIVE EASY VERSES" BY BRUCE LESNICK]
[音乐 - 布鲁斯·莱斯尼克的《现代物理学五首简单诗句》]
Act Four, The Art of Adult Conversation. We end our program today with this fable of the consequences of saying more than you truly understand, from Alexa Junge.
第四幕，成人谈话的艺术。今天我们以这个讲述言过其实的后果的寓言结束我们的节目，来自亚历克莎·琼格。
I know everybody loves their grandmother, but I really, really loved my grandmother. I still dream about her kitchen. From the time I could ride my bike to her house, pretty much every day I'd pedal over after school, drink Fresca, and listen while Grandma Maxine, mostly known as Mac, would hold court.
我知道每个人都爱他们的祖母，但我真的，真的很爱我的祖母。我仍然梦想着她的厨房。从我能骑自行车去她家的时候起，几乎每天放学后我都会骑车过去，喝Fresca，听着祖母玛克辛——大部分人叫她麦克——在那儿高谈阔论。
While all the other kids were getting high and listening to Marshall Crenshaw, I was sitting in my grandmother's kitchen, eating Christmas colored, coconut covered ice cream snowballs, while she dropped ashes and pontificated about life in New York in the '20s and '30s, her work designing costumes for the WPA Theatre, her views about sex, communists, sex with communists. I don't know if she was as progressive as she pretended to be around me, but it was my grandmother who told me, sleep with a bunch of men, so that when the right one comes along, you'll know what you're doing.
当其他孩子都在吸毒、听马歇尔·克伦肖的时候，我正坐在祖母的厨房里，吃着圣诞色、椰子覆盖的冰淇淋雪球，同时她弹着烟灰，高谈阔论着20年代和30年代的纽约生活，她为WPA剧院设计服装的工作，她对性、共产主义者、与共产主义者发生性行为的看法。我不知道她是否像她在我不远表现得那么进步，但正是我的祖母告诉我：“和一群男人睡吧，这样当对的人出现时，你就知道自己在做什么了。”
That I didn't have a boyfriend was of little consequence, since for all intents and purposes, my grandmother was my boyfriend. Sometimes at night, after my parents were asleep, my brother would bang on my door and snarl at me to quit hogging the phone. Then, as he left, he'd say, oh, and say hi to Grandma for me.
我没有男朋友无关紧要，因为实际上，我的祖母就是我的男朋友。有时在晚上，当我的父母睡着后，我哥哥会砰砰敲我的门，咆哮着让我别霸占电话。然后，当他离开时，他会说：“哦，帮我向祖母问好。”
Our bond was so strong, I was moved to write Joni Mitchell influenced ditties about it, which I would play and sing loudly on the piano in our tiny house. Actually, I had written a whole anthology of songs about adolescent yearning, which I scratched into my musical notebook. Songs from this period included "Drifter," "Rainbow Blues," " Where Is My Rainbow?" and then of course, the aforementioned testament to grandma love, "For A Friend," which went a little something like this.
我们之间的联系如此紧密，我被感动去写关于它的乔尼·米歇尔风格的小调，我会大声在小房子的钢琴上弹唱。其实，我写过整本关于青少年渴望的歌曲选集，我把它们刻在我的音乐笔记本上。那个时期的歌曲包括《流浪者》、《彩虹蓝调》、《我的彩虹在哪里？》，当然，还有前面提到的祖母爱的见证，《为了一个朋友》，它是这样唱的。
[SINGING] Coffee and ginger snaps, you give to me a chance to be myself. Feathers and silver rings, old cuckoo clocks, and quiet talks together.
[唱歌] 咖啡和姜饼，你给我一个做回自己的机会。羽毛和银戒指，老布谷鸟钟，和我们在一起安静的谈话。
That I never actually performed my composition for her was of little matter, since it was pretty much common knowledge that I was her favorite, and in case you had any questions, she was mine.
我从来没有真正为她表演过我的作品并不重要，因为我最受她喜爱是众所周知的，如果你们有什么问题的话，她也是我最喜欢的。
Around the time I was thirteen, I started to become aware of a rich history of favoritism in my family. My mom, the story went, had been my Grandfather Marvin's favorite. He took her to museums, taught her to paint, exposed her to Ogden Nash, Arthur Miller, made her play the cello like he did. And because my mother was taken under my grandfather's wing, my uncle came to belong to my grandmother, just like I did.
大约在我十三岁左右时，我开始意识到我家有着丰富的偏袒历史。故事是这样的，我妈妈曾是我祖父马文的最爱。他带她去博物馆，教她画画，让她接触奥格登·纳什、亚瑟·米勒，让她像他一样拉大提琴。由于我母亲被我祖父带在身边，我舅舅成了我祖母的人，就像我一样。
Because my grandfather died when I was six, I never really knew him. He was a beloved teacher. There is no question he was charismatic and multi-talented. The thing is, I'm not exactly sure how nice he was to his wife. Maybe it's not even true, but I remember my father saying how dismissive he could be of my grandmother, how much she blossomed after his death. So as far as I could tell, the Oedipal brouhaha that made it difficult for my mother and grandmother to get along had also paved the way for me. I was getting to have the relationship with my grandmother that my mother never had.
因为我祖父在我六岁时就去世了，所以我从不真正认识他。他是一位受人尊敬的老师。毫无疑问，他很有魅力，多才多艺。问题是，我不确定他对他妻子有多好。也许这都不是真的，但我记得我父亲说他对我祖母是多么不屑，她在去世后又是多么焕发了青春。所以据我所知，导致我母亲和祖母相处不融洽的俄狄浦斯式的喧闹，也为我铺平了道路。我得到了我母亲从未有过的与祖母的关系。
And to my mom's enormous credit, she never even told me about the trouble between them until I started to see some tension and made the mind-bending leap that relationships are complex, and things aren't always what they seem. Suddenly I started to wonder if me being Grandma's favorite wasn't just about me being her favorite. Maybe I was a pawn in some kind of game. Grandma Maxine didn't get Mom, so instead she went for me. Maybe I was just a chump. I needed to get the bottom of it right away.
而且对我妈妈巨大的功劳是，她甚至直到我开始看到一些紧张，并产生了一个令人费解的飞跃，即关系是复杂的，事情并不总是像它们看起来的那样，她才告诉我她们之间的问题。突然间，我开始怀疑我成为祖母的最爱不仅仅是因为我成为她的最爱。也许我是一场游戏里的棋子。祖母玛克辛没得到妈妈，所以她转而选择了我就行。也许我只是个傻瓜。我需要立刻弄清楚它。
There wasn't any plan. And even now, I have to strain to remember what I was thinking on that day, because I wasn't. It was a spur of the moment decision. I really can't explain what happened. I know I went to her house after school, but instead of our usual meeting in the kitchen, I crossed into the living room. We chit-chatted, like grownups. My grandmother's ash dropped. She caught it in her hand. Then I launched in.
没有任何计划。即使现在，我得费力回忆那天我在想什么，因为我根本没想。那是冲动的决定。我真的无法解释发生了什么。我知道放学后我去了她家，但没有像往常那样在厨房会面，我穿过客厅。我们像大人一样闲聊。祖母的烟灰掉了。她用手接住了。然后我开始了。
I was thinking, if my husband spent all of his time with our daughter and acted like he liked her more than me, that would be a pretty hard pill to swallow. I would probably hold on tight to my son and treat him like he was my favorite. I remember she sat down and got herself an ashtray. For 45 minutes, we talked about her marriage. I offered up my special insights about how her distant relationship with her father probably contributed to her dependence on my Grandfather Marvin. Maybe that's why she stopped working after having such a promising career.
我想，如果我的丈夫把所有时间都花在我们的女儿身上，并且表现得好像他比我还喜欢她，那将是一颗很难吞下的药丸。我可能会紧紧抓住我的儿子，把他当成我的最爱。我记得她坐下来，给自己拿了一个烟灰缸。在45分钟里，我们谈论了她的婚姻。我提供了我的特殊见解，关于她与她父亲的疏远关系是如何促成她对祖父马文的依赖的。也许这就是为什么她在拥有如此有前途的职业后停止工作的原因。
I remember feeling exhilarated, like I was onto something, mapping out a new world. Since I was now a member of the big kids psychology club, I could kick it up a notch. In fact, I had to. Are you very sad about your father's funeral? You do realize he's dead and he's never coming back, don't you? Don't you?
我记得感到兴奋，就像我发现了一些东西，正在规划一个新世界。因为我现在是大孩子心理学俱乐部的成员，我得加强一下。事实上，我必须这样做。你对你父亲的葬礼感到很悲伤吗？你确实意识到他死了，他永远不会回来了，不是吗？不是吗？
She wasn't resistant or defensive. She answered here and there, blew smoke rings. In fact, she seemed utterly unfazed, so much so, that when we had finished our tete-a-tete, I went off to roller skate and didn't come back until a few hours later when I was either hungry or wanted a ride home. I rang the doorbell. No answer, so I went around back.
她没有抵触或防御。她在这里和那里回答，吹着烟圈。事实上，她看起来完全没受影响，以至于当我们结束了我们的私下交谈后，我去溜旱冰，直到几小时后，当我饿了或想搭车回家时才回来。我按了门铃。没人回答，所以我绕到了后面。
Through the screen door, I could see Maxine was sitting in the dark living room in her bathrobe. I had the distinct impression that when she had heard me at the door, she hadn't moved a muscle. How long she had been sitting there I couldn't tell, but she was sniffling and blowing her nose. I went inside. She apologized for not answering the door. What's going on, I said. Aren't you feeling well? She responded simply, some of the things you said upset me.
透过纱门，我可以看到玛克辛正坐在昏暗的客厅里，穿着浴袍。我有一个明显的印象，当她听到我在门口时，她没动一下。她坐在那里多久了，我无法判断，但她在抽泣，擦着鼻涕。我走了进去。她为没有开门道歉。我说：“怎么了？”你身体不舒服吗？她简单地回答说：“你说的一些话让我心烦。”
Oh, she'd been sniffling because she had been crying. I didn't recognize it because I'd never seen her cry. It was so out of character I didn't even know she could cry, let alone be so upset by something I said. The terrifying thing is that somewhere I think I had even expected my grandmother to congratulate me for being so clever in cracking the codes. But while I was tossing off all these adult words and ideas, I didn't really understand what they would mean to her. I don't know, I was just kicking it on up. I just wanted to share. In fact, what I'd done is more along the lines of getting a sawed off shotgun, shooting willy-nilly into her house, and then coming back 20 minutes later and asking if she had redecorated.
噢，她一直在抽泣是因为她在哭。我没认出来是因为我从没见过她哭。这太不符合她的性格了，我甚至不知道她会哭，更不用说被我说的话弄得这么心烦。可怕的是，我在某个地方想，我甚至预料到我的祖母会祝贺我如此聪明地破解了密码。但当我抛出所有这些成人词汇和想法时，我并不真正明白它们对她意味着什么。我不知道，我只是在随性而为。我只是想分享。事实上，我所做的更像是拿着一把截短的猎枪，在她的房子里胡乱射击，然后20分钟后回来问她是否重新装修了。
I don't know how I got home. I think my dad came and got me and my bike. At dinner, I sort of mentioned that Grandma had kind of maybe been distressed about something. My mother had clearly been debriefed, which meant that my grandmother had called my mother and told her what happened, which was, as far as I knew, unprecedented, since the only thing my grandmother spoke to my mother about was her weight and inability to handle money. I guess she was upset, I conjectured. Well, my mother said, what did you expect?
我不知道我是怎么回家的。我想是我爸爸来接我和我的自行车。在晚餐时，我提到了祖母因为什么事有点心烦。我母亲显然被详细告知了，这意味着我祖母给我母亲打电话，告诉我发生了什么，据我所知，这是前所未有的，因为我祖母和我母亲谈论的唯一事情就是她的体重和理财能力。我想她很心烦，我推测。嗯，我妈妈说：“你指望什么呢？”
After that, things were different. I'd still sit in her kitchen while she held court, but something was lost. When she'd be quiet like she'd been in the living room, I'd start to worry I was screwing everything up again, and then I'd work very hard to try to keep her laughing. It was like after that, she knew I could hurt her, and I knew I could hurt her. There weren't going to be any words that could undo the words I had sent out into the universe. She couldn't trust me anymore. And we could never go back.
在那之后，事情就不一样了。我仍然会坐在她的厨房里听她高谈阔论，但有些东西丢了。当她像在客厅里那样安静时，我会开始担心我又搞砸了一切，然后我会非常努力地想让她笑。就像在那之后，她知道我可以伤害她，我也知道我可以伤害她。没有哪句话可以撤销我发送到宇宙中的那些话。她不再信任我了。我们再也回不去了。
I thought about it a lot over the years, how in a matter of minutes, I irreversibly corrupted what had been the most precious relationship in my life, and how it happened without me even knowing I was doing it. I dream about it, sitting across from my grandmother, light slipping through Venetian blinds on a yellow grey Southern California afternoon. Some of the things you said upset me. Some of the things you said upset me.
这些年来我思考了很多，在几分钟内，我是如何不可逆转地破坏了我生命中最珍贵的关系，以及它是如何在不知不觉中发生的。我梦到它，坐在祖母对面，光线透过威尼斯百叶窗射入黄色灰色的南加州午后。“你说的一些话让我心烦。”“你说的一些话让我心烦。”
Alexa Junge is a writer in Los Angeles.
亚历克莎·琼格是洛杉矶的一位作家。
Well, our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, and Sarah Koenig. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Laura Bella, Seth Lind, PJ Vogt, and Emily Youssef.
嗯，我们今天的节目由丽莎·波拉克和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、简·费尔特斯和莎拉·凯尼格。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自托德·巴克曼、劳拉·贝拉、塞思·林德、PJ沃格特和艾米丽·尤瑟夫。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, where you can sign up for our free weekly podcast, absolutely free. And you just have a little time left to enter our new t-shirt design contest, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，在那里你可以注册我们的免费每周播客，完全免费。你只有一点点时间来参加我们的新T恤设计大赛，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持]
WBEZ management oversight by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who always has this advice for me.
WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他总是给我这个建议。
Sleep with a bunch of men, so that when the right one comes along, you'll know what you're doing.
和一群男人睡吧，这样当对的人出现时，你就知道自己在做什么了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带给你们更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。